y la mayoría de nosotros estamos
familiarizados con los perros
muchas veces conocidos como el mejor
amigo del hombre y lo fascinante sobre
ellos es que pertenecen a una sola
especie aún cuando existen diferentes
tipos de perros y diferentes razas que
se ven muy diferentes pero el hecho de
que sea una sola especie indica que si
tenemos un macho y una hembra cualquier
par en teoría se podrían reproducir y
tener descendencia aunque por ejemplo en
el caso de este perrito y este podría
ser algo muy complicado pero una
pregunta muy interesante es de dónde
vienen los perros y por qué hay razas de
perros tan especializadas por ejemplo
aquí está el rottweiler que es bueno
para protección o están los terriers que
son especialistas en perseguir roedores
o también están los border collie que
son muy buenos arreando otro tipo de
animales la respuesta es simple ha sido
a través de la selección artificial y la
domesticación recuerden que en cualquier
población de una especie
existe variación de la misma especie y
cuando hablamos de selección natural
significa que el ambiente se encarga de
seleccionar algunas de las variaciones
que ayudarán a la supervivencia oa la
reproducción para que después sea eso lo
que predomine así es como ocurre la
evolución pero la selección artificial y
domesticación es el proceso en donde los
humanos intervienen y en lugar de
esperar a que la naturaleza siga su
curso el ser humano es el factor
selectivo eligiendo cual especie se
reproduce y cuál no y cuando existe ese
tipo de selección artificial el cambio
en la especie puede ocurrir mucho más
rápido así que la crianza es
esencialmente selección artificial y
todos los perros como estos como los
conocemos tienen ancestros que se ven
como un lobo que fueron un lobo en algún
momento de las primeras etapas de la
existencia del lobo algunos de ellos
evolucionaron en perros
pero en ese entonces lo que ocurrió fue
más parecido a la selección natural
tradicional donde hace decenas de miles
de años mientras nuestros ancestros
cazaban y recolectaban tal vez dejaban
comida por aquí y por allá y algunos
lobos que resultaron ser las variaciones
de aquellos que se sentían más cómodos
acercándose a los humanos se
beneficiaron de obtener un poco de esos
sobrantes y restos que los seres humanos
dejaban pero con el tiempo tal vez los
seres humanos se dieron cuenta de que
era útil tener a esos lobos alrededor
porque de alguna manera brindaban
protección puede ser que con el tiempo
empezaron a criar a los lobos para que
así fueran más amistosos y especialmente
buenos con alguna tarea en particular
como por ejemplo protección o para
perseguir algún tipo de animal o
recuperar cosas entonces permitieron que
esos lobos se reprodujeran y con el
tiempo después de decenas de miles de
años evolucionaron de lobos a perros
y una vez que ya existieron los perros
las razas se fueron haciendo más
especializadas hasta llegar a estos por
ejemplo para los border collie fueron
muchos años y muchas generaciones de
cría en donde los pastores de ovejas
escogieron a los perros que eran buenos
creando ovejas
ahora los terrier vienen de perros que
eran buenos persiguiendo roedores pero
la crianza de los perros parecidos a los
rottweiler resultó en perros que son muy
buenos para la protección y la defensa
pero no solamente los perros son
producto de la selección artificial y
domesticación en realidad cualquier
animal que encuentres en una granja es
producto de la selección artificial y la
domesticación por ejemplo un jabalí un
cerdo salvaje se ve así mientras que los
cerditos que podemos encontrar en una
granja son así porque fueron elegidos
por cualidades como la docilidad y otras
aquellas cualidades con las que fueron
menos agresivos y más fáciles de cuidar
pero la selección artificial y
domesticación no se aplica únicamente a
los animales prácticamente todo lo que
se pueden encontrar en la sección de
productos del supermercado es resultado
de la selección artificial y
domesticación tal vez existan
variaciones salvajes de estos vegetales
y frutas pero en más de 10.000 o 15.000
años de agricultura humana cada
generación de nuevos cultivos ha sido
elegida de las cosechas que son más
grandes que saben mejor y que han podido
crecer en diferentes climas así al
permitir que esas variaciones se
reprodujeran con el tiempo resultaron en
las cosechas y cultivos domesticados que
tenemos hoy